good morning slash good afternoon
uh how are you doing i'm doing great
uh you know honestly i woke up about 20
minutes ago which is weird
seeing how it's like uh 7 30 in moscow
pm
uh but uh yeah it's a great start to a
day
wait how did you are you filming
something uh
we're finishing some post work at the
same time for another project so it's
kind of like
as it should be i love it that's the way
it should be cool
uh um if you so i before we get into why
uh nobody which congratulations on um
i i have a lot to say about that i ask
everyone the same first few questions
uh the first of which is if uh what tv
show
would you love to guest direct well i
know that uh jonathan nolan and lisa joy
are doing um
fallout uh and that's probably my um
you know my favorite video game of all
time pretty very video game series
so that would be that'll be that would
be very exciting
uh what movie or movies do you think
you've seen the most
oh it would have to be it's probably
uh you know low low 20s
uh low 20s uh views but i'd say
it's either hot fuzz or anchorman
oh okay both both are fantastic
um what was it uh uh
why so long after hardcore henry
uh i would imagine after that movie came
out uh people must have been like
we want to make a movie with you um so
what was it that
that kept you on the sidelines doing
other stuff
but not making another feature
um
anything what's a good honest answer
that paints me in
in a decent light yeah i think the
honest answer was this
we were in talks with the russo brothers
for a long time uh for a film called sue
dad
um and they were producing and they
wrote it
i was a big fan of that script and i had
a take on it
um and i got
i passed at the very last minute i got
right after our hardcore opens
opened um i got pneumonia you know how
when you're at war
your body keeps you it knows that
there's no way you can be sick right now
so for three years it took that it took
to make hardcore i was completely
for the first time in my life i've never
gotten sick there's just no opportunity
to do so
um and i after moscow's premiere which
was the last premiere
uh foreign the next morning i woke up in
the hospital pneumonia and i spent three
weeks there
and uh in that half catatonic state with
all the ivs and everything i
passed on sudet which then became
extraction
um so after that happened i
passed because i wanted to do something
that was self-generated which was an
interesting thought at the time
i took me years to understand that it
was the right choice to do first i was
kind of kicking myself in the head
but um i wrote uh and co-wrote quite a
few scripts
uh some might still happen hopefully
we're working on that and um i did a lot
of um
a lot of music videos and a lot of
commercials and just kind of kept
training the directorial muscle
so to speak i've spoken to a lot of
directors that talk about
how at the end of a shoot they just
collapse
it's uh it's it's it's a thing i've
heard from many people
it's it's it's um i remember watching i
think it was platoon
and charlie sheen there's a scene when
he's in the in the
in the jungle at night and it's raining
and i remember looking at that going i'd
be
dead in the first night not from the
bullets but i'd be dead just from
every you know the weather it's
impossible to survive and then
and again comparing filmmaking to wars
is is is a silly thing to say it's
obviously
we have it you know the stakes are quite
a little bit
lower for us uh but um
the body just does a wonderful thing
where it knows it just can't afford it
can't afford any downtime so it just it
goes on overpower but afterwards you
switch off i remember reading about was
i think it was
a bridge too far uh was who directed
bridge too far david
i don't it wasn't david lean wasn't i i
want to say but i don't think it was but
i want to see
uh one second i can't let this sorry uh
bridge too far
uh i should know this i love that movie
what's wrong with me
it was richard attenborough
there we go close enough no not close
enough at all god damn it
but um but i remember reading that he
slept
for a week literally a week after the
film wrapped
you know it's sleeper you get up you eat
uh you go to the bathroom you go back to
bed
and uh i can i can appreciate with that
uh how that happens yeah i we could
spend a whole bunch of time on this
because and i could relate story after
story of what i've heard
but what did you learn making um
hardcore henry that you wanted to apply
to like uh to nobody or anything that
you were
that you did in the future might sound a
little silly
but the art the best thing i learned was
the art
of movie magic or the art of movie lying
i guess where
uh what we really have to do is
directors a lot of the time or
in fact most of the time is to you know
we don't do things for real
and obviously you present them as real
as you can depending on the genre you're
going for
but as an example there's a card
chase and hardcore henry and there's a
moment where he catches up to the bad
guy's truck
and he climbs on the side and gets up to
the roof and he jumps down
through the uh to the port before the
bridge
kills him and we didn't have much money
in that movie
and i remember arguing with my producer
who i love very much katya
uh and we built we built the back of the
truck for as we're chasing it
you know we climb up and we have to use
a regular sized truck we need to make it
big to fit the interior
scene already shot so we built this huge
rig for the back this this this just
this wooden wall that looked very metal
and worked and i remember saying we need
to have the same
width on top of the truck as he climbs
up because that's gonna just
it doesn't make any sense if he's on
this huge thing in the back and he
climbs up and it's thinner it's
the audience is gonna know et cetera and
kaiser's telling ilya
it's movie making you don't need we
can't afford to build this huge thing
and i would like we have to build it
and this was ilia back and i hate to
talk about myself in third person
but you know 2012 2013 ilya
was adamant we built this thing and i'm
glad she talked me out of it back then
but i was very hesitant that this is not
going to work
and obviously when you watch the movie
you never notice the difference the size
literally jumps
becomes twice as small and that's an
example of the kind of things where
you understand how to spend resources
wisely how to spend your pre-production
wisely
how to spend your time
rewriting the script wisely and
obviously when you're shooting
you don't spend energy we don't expend
it where you really don't need to
concentrate on really important things
and that comes with experience and when
you start to understand
what you really need to be sure of and
what ultimately
no one but you is gonna know and that is
sort of the
the art of movie magic completely that
makes a lot of sense actually
um so uh i read that and
of course i could be wrong but i read
that uh for you to do an american
project
uh you had like a list of things you
wanted like you wanted to work
with 87 north you wanted it to be an
actor that played against type
um you know all these kind of things and
then
this project sort of lands um what was
it like for you
hearing about this project because it
meant like every thing that you wanted
in a project um
the email from my agent because i that i
was talking to my simpson agent and uh i
brought that up before as sort of if we
were to do an american action film this
is sort of the ingredients i'd love to
have
and then i get the email and says can
you surely see receive and that happened
literally like i think you know
six seven months after i we talked about
it um
so it's it said boba wood and kirk lead
uh derek colstad
script 87 north producing so
uh as i was reading it it's it's nice to
read
sometimes it's nice to read a script
knowing what the intent is
of this of this star um and he just
click
clicked right away it's very rarely with
scripts just
again click right away usually it's you
read and you think about it there's
things you like things you don't like
you think about you can improve it how
you can make it more
your own how you can expand some of the
themes this one it made sense and i
think the most
most important thing that happened at
the end of my first read through i
thought i understood what this film
really needs to be about and what it is
about
and i remember talking to bob my first
conversation with bob
um i didn't talk about the action at all
i just
said bob this is i think this movie is
about um
it's about a guy addicted to violence it
really is an addiction drama that's
going to be
masquerading as a popcorn action
extravaganza and if we come back from
that angle that was
going to make it special because the
action is going to be great you know we
can make it great there's examples we
it's it's just it's not the question of
that it's how do you make it special
how to make it stand out um
today and i think bob really um
really appreciated the fact that i
approached it from a story and character
character standpoint rather than just
talk about how cool the shots are going
to be
sure uh i heard when you went in because
obviously you pitched on the movie
i heard that you had like a 30-page
treatment
and it was during the treatment that
they were like stop
just you got it um is that true uh
close it was it was a 30 i actually
looked up the other day
just so i was made sure i wasn't
bullshitting anybody it was 28 pages
and they stopped me on page 14 which is
exactly halfway through
and they said that's enough i think we
think we get it
and i was like okay cool and i was
thinking is this a good sign probably
not a good sign they didn't let me
finish
um but i went back to the hotel i got a
call same night saying
you got it so and i was before that i
was thinking i'm not quite sure
so it's like actors going to auditions
every time you think you've messed it up
you actually did a great job and vice
versa
got it well also i think that uh you
know they must have liked what you were
selling
you know there was um i
i mean yes it's
that's an arguable fact right there but
uh it was uh the treatment was
was made with a lot of love i really put
a lot of heart and soul into that i
wasn't um
you know i do a lot of not so much
anymore but i used to do a lot of
treatments for music videos and
commercials
so i knew um it's a very different world
but with commercials always you know you
do these
50 page treatments which are half the
time that ghost written
you just dictate what the thought is and
there's people who put it together for
you because there's just a lot of work
and
it's i'm lazy uh i'm not but i kind of
am
um and
with a lot of commercial treatments
they're expected to be
just highly detailed uh unnecessarily so
um but with movies
you want to get across just the point of
what you're going to be doing you want
to sell
it systematically look and feel and
that's pretty much it and i just
concentrated on things that i would have
wanted to
to to to hear from the director if i was
a producer on it
that's it so i wanted to myself the same
way i make a movie i want to make sure i
like it
because if i like it there's a chance
some other people i'm not that that
weird and crazy
uh and that's the same thing uh with
the presentation um i
heard that you wanted it to look or feel
a little bit like korean thrillers
like that was something that you brought
up can you talk about which films
maybe you mentioned to everyone or bob
in terms of like maybe watch these just
so you know what i'm looking for
um when i signed on we met with derrick
and bob
um we knew there's going to be a
draft or two more um and as i pitched
my ideas for what what if what we want
to expand upon in the film
and what themes we got to hit harder and
how we're getting to the russian angle
i remember saying bob
i'm sure you've seen some south korean
movies right he's like yeah you know he
saw old boy he saw
the classics and derek obviously seen
everything because
derek loves that genre as much as i do
um i said guys imagine it's
i remember showing bob bittersweet life
and telling him that imagine if it's a
russian making a south korean thriller
in america
and you're the guy that's in it that's
that's how i'm going to approach this
and we not did not tell everybody that
um
because i'm this was pre-parasite right
before everybody knows south korean
movies are uh
but um it was not a hard sell you know
for bob because you know you watch
bittersweet life is not you know we're
not trying to copy it we're not trying
to emulate
much of it except the fact that it is
character driven with great action
and the tone is fairly somber so i said
this but
there will be you know the popcorn
elements that we very very much are
required to have
in the studio summer release which it
was at that point
august 14th i believe his original plan
um uh one of the things that i think
will surprise people about bob
is he he trained for two years for this
movie
even before there was a green light even
before it was
gonna be made and it shows you know like
and we'll talk specifically about the
bus fight and other things that he did
but can you sort of talk about the fact
that he went above and beyond
preparing for this movie more than most
people
for almost anybody um
i think he started a little bit before i
before i signed on so at that point it
was uh i'd say it was about a year and
six or seven months prior to
pre-production that he was already you
know
hitting the gym and working with uh
daniel bernhard the trainer
the actor and the trainer um and um
i remember going to um to 87 11 by lax
where there were
um with our training and there was a
huge room
um the training grounds and
there was i walk in i got my camera and
all this other
you know uh uh camera tools
and um there's keanu reeves training
with 12 people for john wick three
and you know keanu is super proficient
as you expect him to be it's keanu
and i walk past all the cameras and
keanu gives me this look who's this guy
like
my way up kind of make sure the camera's
pointed away because the last thing
anybody wants when they're training is
to have some dude they don't know with
the
camera pointed their way and i walk past
and there's part of the
the big big floor is separated out by
boxes you know every every every stunt
space has lots of boxes they do
everything with boxes
um they make the bus fight out of the
bus out of boxes for
the previous for example the boxes are
very important um
and there's this little room and i walk
in
and bob is sweating his ass off just
working super hard
he's falling down he's getting up he's
falling down he's getting up he's doing
these five consecutive
motions movements throwing the guy
getting thrown himself
and he's super sweaty it's super hard
this is early on in the process for him
and i remember standing in the corner uh
recording with my phone
and i'm as i'm recording bob i turned to
see keanu doing this thing that he's
super great at and i've seen him do and
i you know i
very much enjoy um and i'm turning my
head and here's bob
who's having a hard time doing this i
remember thinking to myself
i hope this movie really does get made
because
i've yet to see this uh talking about
bob
and the effort that
the character is gonna need
and we're gonna show as you know he's
not a well-oiled machine at the start
and he gets there
um you know combined with his
acting abilities was gonna be special
and it shows in the movie bob
bob's fantastic uh you know um uh
when you were filming the movie did you
try and
i know obviously you did not have a ton
of money to make this but did you try
and schedule anything wait a minute we
had millions
exactly there was this was not a marvel
budget
um what i'm basically saying is that did
you try and schedule certain things
for the beginning middle or end of the
shoot based on
you know for certain reasons or was it
sort of like you're just being you're
filming
the way the scheduled god sort of threw
their dice
uh we had a fantastic first ad paul
berry who's you know who's made huge
movies small movies
you know uh he definitely knows this
thing and obviously i
as a as a director uh we all
dream of making movies in sequence of
course it doesn't happen
um and that's okay um
but i think the only day
that stayed with the same plan
throughout pre-production and production
was the day we shot
um um can i i can go into spoilers a
little bit right
uh then when the hitmen come to visit
christopher lloyd's character
because uh obviously um it's my amazing
cameo
uh uh my entrance into big time
hollywood acting
uh but not so much about me but
the second hitman is um north american
audiences will not recognize but he has
uh
a guy called sergey schnur who is
russia's you know
biggest huge rock star uh and he was
touring america he's a friend of mine i
directed a few musical
videos for him uh over the years and i
said look
we're making this movie um we're gonna
have a russian mob want to make it
authentic as possible be great if you
can
show up in fact i remember getting the
first call
about getting a call with bob while
we're shooting a music video for him and
i got all very giddy and he's like you
seem to be very happy today i'm like
well i do believe i
found something i'm going to be doing
next like a movie i'm like yes he's like
in america i'm like i think so he's like
you know there's a throwaway line he's
kind of like between the takes he's like
um
just call me if you want me to meet you
in there just remember that i was like i
i will
you know and then a long time later i
think it was a year and a half after
that
where um i called and showed up but
getting back to your question
it was um because bob was
super over prepared uh we could have
done the action whenever we wanted
we just didn't want to start um the
first day with action because you kind
of you know
the crew has to get the feel for how the
tempo and you know get to know each
other before we get to the really
uh technical uh parts of the shoot but
we um i think we did the act the bus
fight was
end of week two yeah because we started
a monday and i think it was a friday
the second week where it was friday
saturday sunday shoot
three days in a row night shoots uh
which i love night shoots again i'm a
night owl made me very happy
uh yeah in fact the script i'm writing
now it's mostly said at night and i can
i
and i'm sadly gonna have to annoy a lot
a lot a lot of
uh crew members but um i know we're
gonna have a
nicer looking picture because you just
control the lights that's the wonderful
thing it's daytime it can be beautiful
with the right sun but when you're in
winnipeg
you're not gonna get much sun in
november realistically so
lucky we had a lot of the film take
place at night time
um the opening montage of the film is
really well cut
i'm just curious how long for like the i
don't
i don't know how long it is in the movie
it's like you know a minute two minutes
three minutes what
what whatever it may be how long did
that actually take to edit
are you talking about the days of the
week the monday we call it the mandani
montage or you talk about the intro
where he's the song plays and before the
credits
as the questions no not that not the
beginning not the very very beginning
but when you had the montage of him
going to work
monday tuesday wednesday yeah um
i think there were two possible cuts for
that we had one that was another musical
number and we just kind of thought well
it's kind of
silly to have a musical intro which we
all love very much with nina simone's
track
uh or and then follow that up with
another musical
uh number um
musical montage so it was
i don't want to i don't recall exactly
how many days
but it was not it was not
it was definitely not in the script and
we kind of felt that we needed more
because it originally went from uh from
the title sequence straight to
him waking up in the middle of the night
and that sequence was added to show a
little bit more of how
bored he is um and that i don't think it
took that long to um
to put together but it was very
important to have you know that it sets
a perfect tempo no i i think that
sequence actually says a lot about the
character
and where he's at um and i think it's
really smart that you put it in um
well i'll tell you originally when when
we were talking about it
i hated the idea of beyonce
it's it's it's because it's so it's
always this the spite of
and i have the same thing with hardcore
where we had all these different cuts
and i would
you know we put some roth in the
beginning of hardcore and william put
that in the editor
and i remember watching i was and i was
like that's not what we meant you can't
wait
and then i remember just the inner voice
saying ilya shut the hell up
look at him with a fresh pair of eyes i
know it's hard i know you're not going
to be subjective
but that's the job right now as
objective as possible it doesn't work it
does
shut the [ __ ] up enjoy it and same thing
happened here so it's
two films in a row where i'm um
uh hesitant at first but then
very happy with it later yeah i've
spoken to filmmakers
who um uh have taken out jokes
that are huge jokes but it's no longer
funny to them
so they have to watch it again with an
audience to realize this is still
funny even if i don't think it's funny
mm-hmm of course
it's the idea that you're being too
close to material is absolutely true
and i remember i think it was i can't
remember called the writer
uh
[Music]
i think it was thomas thomas lennon i
was
watching interview with him when he was
talking about uh
where he's talking about how as you as
he works as a writer and the studio says
uh we need a fresh pair of eyes and used
to get really annoyed
when when they would say that to him and
um
didn't realize it's a blessing that
means everything's gonna work and they
just really want a fresh pair of eyes
nothing wrong with his eyes it just
needs to be a fresh pair of eyes
as a director uh it's
you know it's um it's not like you have
the opportunity to
be like all right let's get another
director into work right you got to
really [ __ ] something
up to piss off the producers and and
then the studio to to your place
and as this was a very sort of friendly
project all the way through
uh and i'm not just saying it really was
i had a [ __ ] great time
um it's important
to be able to open your ears and really
listen to what people around you are
saying and when we had that first cut
and i had not the first cup but that cut
of the mundanity sequence
as we call it uh it was an ilia this is
great i know it's not the slow burn
intro but it's
great look at it again and i would look
at it again and be like you know what
i'm gonna enjoy it because you know it's
just that's the way it is
uh speaking of first cuts uh how long
the movie's about
an hour and a half uh how long was your
first cut of the film
i think the the assembly must have been
one hour 51 one hour or maybe
49. uh it was never that long it was 100
pages
uh maybe 105 page script um
at least as we went in because there was
a lot of reiterations as we were
shooting
but um the biggest change
that occurred between the director's cut
in the final cut
is there was a fantastic
uh idea to
[Music]
condense act two there was a bigger uh
there's i think
there i think we cut three scenes out of
the film and there were mostly to do
with um
uh michael ironside's character uh
uh hutch's father-in-law as he would
call and find out who his son is and it
was just a longer
an unnecessary sequence we always loved
it in the script and we shot it's great
scenes and it was
you know i was talking to billy
mcclellan who plays the brother-in-law
and i was saying billy
uh things are changing a little bit
you're gonna have your moment to shine
but it's not gonna be as much screen
time but it is what it is you know
i mean i remember him saying well movies
all that matters i'm like god damn right
um but um
it's um i think that was the biggest
change that condensed i think
seven or eight minutes true or false uh
you
you cast michael ironside not because
he's a good actor
not because his part is important in the
movie you literally just wanted to geek
out all day about total recall in
robocop and that's why he's in the movie
guilty
that's all i would do
we were told by our casting the canadian
casting director that
uh iron sight is available and he liked
the script
and we're like uh i don't think there's
any further point in discussing if he
wants to come in and do this
lucky to have him um and he was just
i think you know there was something
i didn't talk to him before i saw him on
set because we knew he was gonna do a
great job he's not an actor you audition
there's not an actor you
really need to talk to before you get in
there and if we're
uh shooting um i'll tell you a little
michael ironside story if we have a
little bit of time
uh we're shooting a scene that but that
had to go from the cut but
uh he's um it's a bar scene he's pretty
much picking up a rotary phone and he's
taking his time
it's a one long dolly and as he's you
know calling the guy
at the pentagon and trying to find out
information about hutch's character
and it's a very tight bar
little irish bar in winnipeg and
you michael doing his great job it's a
winner he you just
pull in and push in and picks up the
phone he dials and he talks
but we couldn't get the movement of the
dolly perfect uh
and michael calls me over after take
three uh elia could do you
can come over here for a second and we
chatted you know briefly before that we
introduced it was it was great he was
very warm to begin with
so he's very stern's like ilya is this
one of those movies where the director
knows exactly what they want and they're
gonna make everybody suffer until they
get it
um yes michael that is the case
and i was i'm expecting a hail storm or
anything i'm just because you don't know
you know i met the guy
you know two hours ago and
he says okay okay so tell me um are you
married
i'm like uh yes michael i am he's like
how long i'm like i don't know 10 11
years maybe maybe a dozen
and he's like okay okay she'd be one
very
patient lady
and he slaps my back and so let's go and
we just you know
we do another couple another couple of
takes and he keeps on acing it and then
we have to catch up to
his level of uh awesomeness so that was
fun but he was um
he really is just like chris lloyd just
like bob very very um
very um a very warm individual that
sounds like i'm
like an alien host but uh
but he really was he was just this this
very uh it was when we wrapped him in
the shoot i was very sad to see him uh
say goodbye um whose idea was it to put
the touch of evil poster
in hutcher's basement um
i think we were discussing roger fires
our production designer and we said
let's try to make a poster and let's
make it over the top
because it's going to be there for such
a brief period of time and very few
people will notice and those that
that notice it will get a kick out of it
so um
it was me in conjunction with our
production designer yeah
i thought that was a good uh a good
touch um one of those it's kind of a
little
yeah should i go ahead no no i mean uh
one of the things
that i thought was ingenious is that you
crafted an action set piece
with christopher lloyd where he doesn't
have to stand up you know he
he's an older gentleman so obviously he
can only do so much
but there's it's a great little bit um
where he's he's just sitting mm-hmm
thank you i'm glad you enjoyed it it's
um
[Music]
it was the first thing we shot with him
as well we had the we had the
his conversation with uh with uh with
bob and then it's straight into the
action
and um he was um i was just watching
behind the scenes i was sent for
approval the other day
and uh it
i don't like seeing myself on camera but
uh there's shots
of footage of me just talking to lloyd
and i can see how happy i am
so uh and i was happy for two reasons
one it's gonna be
i knew it was gonna be a great scene it
was working exactly as intended until
i'm shooting christopher lloyd shooting
people actually shooting me
so you know uh
one for the memories yeah
it's it's a really good sequence um
let's jump into the bike uh the bus
fight sequence um
uh that was it's brutal it's so well
done
and i like the fact that the first half
of the bus sequence has no music
it's just a sound of violence and then
when he gets back
up from being kicked out of the window
that's when all of a sudden like the
anger turns on there's music
can you sort of talk about putting that
sequence together and what you wanted to
accomplish
um well first up thank you i'm glad you
enjoyed it um
we and thank you for saying is brutal
because that was part of the goal um i
don't see how anyone's going to watch
that and be like ooh that's team
good good is what i have to say to that
um it was always planned to be
um that way musically in terms of the
score would always kick
in in the finale uh because we just
wanted it to be
you know as as um i think when music
kicks in generally especially if a song
kicks and now that it does in the bus
but
when a song kicks in that's when the
audience feels like it's okay to relax
we know it's gonna be fine you don't
play songs
when there's danger for the character
and i've learned that editing and
re-editing hardcore
hence the queen track uh which was a
choice to let everybody breathe out a
little bit
and to borrow from edgar wright at the
same time i was probably i was very
proud when i when i put that scene
together and we put it with
the um with the queen's song
um i remember thinking god is such a
great choice celia
so original so well-made and i was like
[ __ ] me
sean of the dead all right i just seen
that movie you know a dozen times
great all right borrow from the best
it's okay um
but um it was that scene was very
heavily uh previous the bus fight
we spent a lot of time talking about it
with gregor mentor our stunt coordinator
a lot of time with bob and greg and the
team inside the bus just walking around
and talking and coming up with things
and
dropping things it was totally was very
important
to make sure there's levity amidst all
the carnage and i've learned
from hardcore that and i call it
hardcore because in russia it was still
called hardcore it's all in america that
was hardcore henry
um i learned that you don't need to go
for a big laugh
to get a big laugh or to get a big
chuckle uh
when it's um placed next to violence
because
by contrast comedy and violence elevate
each other
[Music]
uh which is a wonderful tool and that's
some of the things you learn
uh the more you shoot the more you put
the movie together but um
it was always meant to be brutal i
always described it as um
bob's character should be like a
wolverine not
hugh jackman's wolverine but the
wolverine the animal
if you watch how a real wolverine fights
and what he does
that's that's what uh bob's attitude
uh is in that scene and that kind of was
the key to
um the key to um
writing you know planning it out um
and there were very few surprises and
sort of things we changed along the way
as we were shooting
uh again because we just over prepped in
the schedule like this you can't
um you can't just um you know spend a
lot of time
uh going oh what about this what about
that you know exactly what you want you
go in there you shoot it you the best
your abilities and
hope that it works what more can i have
about the bus fight scene
well i'm going to ask you something like
that where you pre well i'll go
further um obviously you pre-visit that
you're thinking about everything
how much are you with that sequence how
much is
everything with where the camera is
going to be all figured out before you
step on set and how much are you sort of
thinking
can i cheat a camera there for extra
coverage you know like
talk a little bit about camera placement
uh there wasn't
um there wasn't much improvisation i'd
say about
15 i'd say 20 is probably overreaching
uh but i'd say 15 uh these things that
you know you got to be flexible the
wonderful thing with having
being over prepped and knowing
everything up front is that you
understand what's important and what's
not important
so uh just as we had days where we had a
scene
with 15 shots lined up and we get there
and we watched the actors and pablo and
i would be like
talk to turn the first cd and say throw
out the shooting plan we're gonna do
three shots and that's it that's all you
need
so and that comes from knowing exactly
what before i flew out to canada i did
two thousand storyboards so as i arrived
i put them up on the wall and
one of the producers and bob would
arrive and be like this is the movie
let's talk about it
and you can you know put a little
dialogue in and you walk in and watch
uh a graphic novel basically which
really helped
um but the bus is a very tight space
things things that work while you're
walking around with an iphone
would not necessarily work when you have
you know the uh
a big camera but um it mostly stayed
very very close to uh the original plan
i think one of the things that
we were um
we made a good call and that we shot
more
comedy to have in our back pocket
necessarily like the stop request that
signed with the ping
ping ping i thought maybe will work if
he's just pulling the wire maybe that's
enough but it's great to have that shot
of the thing lighting up and originally
i thought
man it's probably trying too cute and
we're trying too hard but
uh you sit in the edit and you're going
nope i think this is perfect let's
lighten it up there's enough carnage
around
that it's not gonna feel like we're
going for something cheap
yeah no i i actually like that bit it's
fun um
so uh there's a little bit of an homage
to goodfellas
in this movie where um uh was that on
purpose
we were you looking at goodfellas and
being like we're going to do that
um the scene that derek wrote was
julian played by alexis debrick would be
arriving at club and going through
um all the back rooms and seeing the
kitchen and seeing there's a bit of a
drug operation a bit of a some of the
paintings would be in there so we wanted
to pre
i think originally the intent was to
show
julian's whole operation in that one
sequence and as we found the place that
we liked
uh in winnipeg to shoot we didn't
realize that we wanted to do a warner
just because it's just it's a new
introduction so next chapter it's pretty
much the second act
uh of the film um well to me
it's hard sometimes it's it can we can
be broken down into three or five acts
differently
but uh to me always felt like this is
the the title card this is now we're
intrigued we had nobody and now we're
introducing julian
so we wanted to have take our time with
the introduction
and we found the club the basement of
the club was just not
great and as we're standing outside um
i'm looking around and it's a cold
winnipeg evening
and pablo and i started walking around
and i remember crossing the street and
saying
you know i think we should just you know
cut all that unnecessary stuff about him
and show
exactly what's happening in the basement
and just have him go in there and do the
dance that's it you don't need to know
he's a bad guy because we're going to
find out you know a minute and a half
later plus the audience is smart they
know when this guy walks out that
exactly who he is there's a menace
um right away so even though we knew
that that's gonna be the pop song
playing
uh by the way which is a easter egg the
the
is an easter egg if the director talks
about it beforehand uh screw it
um
is it uh yeah sorry i was gonna say
easter eggs are things that a person
watching the movie
would not might notice um and
sometimes it's easter eggs that only the
director knows you know that are
so there's many different versions
there's the things that fans are going
to notice
and things that they might not notice
there's many versions okay
then i feel good revealing this one so
uh because not many fans are gonna know
this one so
the the song that he comes out of the
car i'll come back to the sequence
but because you know my mind just jump
around a little bit um
in fact the only place where i'm really
focused is during writing and
shooting it's strange how uh the
organism works but
um the song that he sings
is a russian pop song from the early 90s
uh
called uh the auditor so reality he's
singing about the character that's going
to be killing him later on uh
and the song is from a girl's
perspective falling in love with with an
auditor which
is exactly the opposite of what happens
in the film so i know the russian crowds
are going to get it we're going to have
a good time but
uh america has not so much i was going
to say i've seen the movie twice i would
never have known
no it's uh of course not you're not uh
from from around these parts but um we
um
i remember reading i was watching
goodfellas in fact i think i was going
through a lot of uh
as we were prepping i was watching even
not that this is
you know trying to be a martin scorsese
movie it's not in the slightest but
uh i remember uh the irishman was coming
out as we're about to shoot so remember
i went on a spree of
watching uh scorsese films and the good
fella has seen the classic you know
warner as he arrives and goes through
the basement and
so it turns out the original script uh
and this is per the imdb trivia so
i might be full of it or they might be
full of it or put that in but
the original scene was him arriving
rayleigh otta
arrives uh at the club door opens and
it's supposed to be a winner as he walks
into the club
but they weren't allowed to use the main
entrance apparently so they had to use
the underground
and that's how the whole sequence was
born so in fact we had the complete
opposite of that we wanted to have
the basement but it kind of sucked we
didn't want to use it so we had to
use an exterior shot which i thought was
kind of cute as a as a counter
as a complete um counter to what
scorsese did but and i was also very
proud of the idea of the car stopping i
was thinking this is such a great moment
he's walking doesn't give a [ __ ]
i love it it's pretty fresh i'm like god
damn a training date
and you know it's ethan hawk and and
denzel walking out of a diner in in the
beginning of that movie
uh and they have the same shot where
denzel walks into a car stop in front of
him it's the same sideways shot that we
we do here so it's great how your mind
makes you feel like
you're absolutely amazing until you
remember that well you're amazing
because you're standing on the shoulders
of giants yeah you know something though
it's very very hard
in the history of cinema which is now
over a hundred you know over 100 years
to um it's just every
almost everything's been done it's
really hard it's all about
the combinations it's all about it's the
story about a hitman going back to his
prior life retirement has been done a
lot of times
it's all about how you present it and
what if you bring something new to the
table and i think tarantino taught
everybody that is that
you can borrow you can get inspired you
can pay homage
but if you do a good job with it and you
bring your own and add your own to it
you're fine and that's what we are all
doing we're all expanding upon
each other's works completely uh how
tough was it working with the kitten
uh on a scale of one to five i'd say
it's
one i think it's only seen in the film
we had to shoot the actors separately
we had a outbreak of um
i'm not sure what the right term for it
is what was it um
the neuro not neuro because that would
be
the norovirus the norovirus that's what
we had uh
for two weeks and plagued our set so we
did the whole wash your hands every 15
minutes
we did that before it was cool um yeah
[Music]
um we had so we had to shoot that whole
scene
uh the detectives and bobs were and
bob's and bob's detective detectives and
bob were never
uh in the same scene together it was all
it was all um uh movie magic
uh not complicated but that was the
complicated part but not the kitten the
kitten was very well behaved um
a lot of experience in films that
couldn't not it didn't but it was
it was it was a professional i would
have never known they weren't
in the same uh scene um yeah so you have
an after the credit scene
was it always going to be that scene was
it how did you come up with that
or how'd that get done well the draft
that i read originally had
uh it had chris lloyd's character and
harry uh who's
played by rizza um we never s
we had the scene with yep what we had
originally was
lloyd takes care of the hitman and then
he disappears
until the after credit scene and same
with
harry never appeared in the film apart
from the radio voice
and the ending the original post-credits
sequence that derek had was
the doors blast opening some corporation
and
the three of them coming in with
shotguns and blasting everybody away
and music would start playing and the
credits would roll over that sequence
and we're reading and saying
great post-credits scenes are
uh they've been in vogue for quite a
while now but i think it's a disservice
that
to not uh include um
the father and the brother in the finale
instead that's where they need to be it
really needs to
we need to escalate the action and the
best way to escalate the action is add
more
uh higher stakes and have more
characters on each side so it wouldn't
be just bob
fighting you know 50 russians it would
be bob
his dad and his brother uniting it makes
thematically makes a lot more sense and
it's also the family coming together
and um that was one of the changes that
we um
that uh that we did during the the
constant rewrites
um my only question and i'm gonna act
and about the film and because i was
watching it again last night
so the obelisk which is the russian
mafia's money correct i'm so i'm so
sorry steven uh
the object oh object i'm very sorry yeah
no no
i i'm sorry for coming up not coming up
for adding a very russian term to an
american movie and going
the guys will remember come on op shaq
yes yes
by the way a little bit of useless fun
fact trivia slash trivia is that
uh we kept calling it the bob shack and
we kept singing the b52 song
uh uh love shaq and we go bob shack babe
yeah that's how much fun we had on this
set
yeah anyway sorry go ahead it's fine so
my only question for you is and this is
a um
a logic slash um suspension of disbelief
question
so the only thing i'm wondering is how
how is their money
in the same city as bob you see what i'm
saying like it's all
like i would have figured that the money
would have been
in russia or something or am i missing
something here
no the way it works and the object is a
very real thing uh
oh absolutely it's it's it's just uh i
think derek found a sexy way of
describing what it is he's saying it's
retirement fund for russia mob
in reality it's not a retirement fund
it's their operations fund
operational fund and there is the the
russian op shack there's a north
american op shack
and it does travel uh and i did talk
by uh you know everybody knows a guy who
knows somebody knows somebody knows
somebody
and i got to this one guy who um
uh or phone explained i just i said this
is what we're gonna be doing it's an
american film we're gonna be doing this
how how how [ __ ] is this can this
happen
a little bit of research never hurts and
um
he said it's uh
you're close enough but if you do large
money
make sure that there's uh you know tens
and twenties
i'm like okay so uh it's um
it is a traveling thing since the film
we never revealed where it was
where the action takes place to me it
was always any town in america if you
look
another i don't know if it's an easter
egg but little thing we added that
all the number plates from different are
from different um
states um because remember the beginning
roger fires the production as i said
where is this taking place we need to
because we need to print those plates we
need to make it you know
that's the job what do we do and i said
just make each car a different plate i
don't care what they are i just want a
different i don't want anybody to know
where we are this is any town in america
this is guys or nobody in the suburbs
make it any town america
so um the
the object as is travels and there is a
north american object it all makes sense
and it's all
um partially true it's all partially
true it's a weird way of putting it but
yes
no that makes sense um because i i yeah
that actually makes sense because i was
wondering i'm like well if is the money
in russia
and like i'm like but i it makes sense
if they have some money in america for
what they need
well the russian mob apparently still
exists in the states so
uh you know it's countless american
films have taught us
so
hollywood does not lie it would never
lie to us ever
they and they've never exaggerated the
truth with anything
no why would they of course that's crazy
talk um
so uh obviously there's the house attack
which we haven't talked about yet
and that is where you know the family's
locked up it's bob
dealing with everyone coming through uh
can you talk about filming that sequence
and is it one of these things because
you know uh the guys at 87
obviously have worked on the john wick
movies and this is you know
uh an attack um you know like sort of
i don't want to say like it's any sort
of because it's not a copy at all but
it's like there's a similar thing
how much are you sort of saying like we
got to get away from that and we got to
do this or how much you know what i mean
um it was never i don't think we ever
said out loud that we're not trying to
do
we got to step away as much as we can
from john wick although i will
uh i greatly agree fondness i recall
as uh as i had my notes for the draft
the first draft i read and i met with
derek
uh i think it was like a second or third
get-together
and you know derek's just a sweetheart
of a guy
and uh first time we met he was like
ilya love to meet your fan of your work
best idea windsor everybody i'm like
nice of you to say it i love it great
uh and um we stayed that with that
throughout i remember calling coming to
derek and saying derek
remember all those things that really
worked in jungwick and made you famous
and made you a lot of money and made you
a highly sought after writer let's have
less of less of that in this
movie um and he was like all right
he was in uh but there was a lot more
wickedness
um there was a lot more world building
that
i felt was not as necessary because
the character um and the story just
seemed
what i love about the story is that it's
it's all based on inner conflict and all
the important
sort of the biggest attraction
in the story for me was what's happening
inside bob's mind rather than
the you know the russian mob and all
those guys if you think about it the
kitty cat bracelet
the um the watch
they don't matter it's they're just an
excuse for him to do what he really
wanted to do for the last
15 years or so so it was um coming back
to your question of them
uh sorry to go such a roundabout way
coming back to
the attack um we re-watched uh the first
quick with pavel our dp
uh during prep and the very different
scenes
in the sense that by this with in the
with um
i think that's the first big action
scene in wic whereas ours is the end of
act two
uh so we kind of know at this point what
bob's character is capable of
uh we knew we only had a day or i think
13 hours to shoot the entire sequence
which is
super tight um and
in fact we were it was so tight that
their plan was
if we get through everything we can go
upstairs and shoot the
baseball bat introduction the first part
of the fight which i really wanted to
get because i wanted that moment of him
breaking the bat
against his legs to me with such a such
a badass moment i wanted bob
to have as many badass moments as
possible um
in this film but um
it's vastly differently structured
whereas jaylen wake is a longer scene
because it is one of the first
uh action encounters with this one it's
more
uh propulsive i'd say we don't focus
uh on any one-on-one fight whereas in
wic it was more prolonged
uh i think there was a little bit more
attackers and plus this one ends the
weight end so we wanted to
get to that peak as quickly as possible
uh while still delivering
the thrills i can't believe you shot
this thing in 13 hours
i would have never known that i would
have never expected to be possible but
hey
again you prep and you have a great team
and you have bob
and you just go at it that's it sure uh
it's gonna be my last question because i
believe you have another interview to go
do very soon
um uh so what exactly do you know what
you're going to do next
what's coming up for uh for you there
are
several projects that um i was told
early on when i arrived in hollywood
2013 after my first music video worked
well they said yeah the way it works you
need to have a lot of irons in the fire
i'm like okay how many is a lot they're
like
aim for five have three i'm like okay so
there was no time to prep anything when
hardcore was happening
and when the movie came out and they
were like what do you want to do next
i'm like
i could pitch what i want but i wouldn't
have something to be brought
to to present um and this time
i've been more you know last you know
three or four years i've like i said
i think early on i told you i've um
i've written and covered in quite a few
scripts
and we have options for um for two books
that i really love
and one is called leaving berlin it's
joseph cannon uh
book um new york times bestseller i
gotta add that because it's apparently
very important
uh not to me but it's important uh to
some
um it's a great story about a guy coming
back
to post-war germany a jew who ran away
comes back feeling like maybe east
germany's gonna be great and then
he gets right in the thick of things and
it's a writer who has to become
a spy uh it's a romantic romantic action
thriller
which is very vastly different and um
i'm very excited
for that to happen if it does uh there's
a contemporary western called the
adventures of benito valenzuela which i
think is my
um um how do you say without sounding
too pretentious it's if you imagine no
country full of men
but with humor that kind of tone that
kind of grittiness but
with um with a little bit of that um
chuckle energy and
i finally got the rights to a book that
i've been after for 20 years
um it's weird i i look back on my
old email account i wrote i wrote to the
author a guy called danny king a british
writer
uh he has a book called the hitman's
diaries which i was a huge fan of
when i was growing up and i wrote him
back then and said
i'd like to make a russian version of
this he had well the rights to take and
i'm sorry let's keep in touch and we
stay in touch all these years and
finally
the rights finally reverted back to him
and i'm like danny i'm there
uh so i'm going to take a stab at that
adaptation to see if that can be made
so um those are the three um
that hopefully one of them will go and
some of them will take a little longer
but
they're all very worthwhile and very
different i think as i progress and i
get better what i do um
there's so many genres and so many
things that there's so many good stories
i'd like to tell
um that hopefully i do have more
opportunity to do so
yeah i also hope this is a really big
hit for you because i had a blast with
it
and i would love to see bob kicking more
ass so
um i'm just throwing that out there uh
but listen congrats
and um good luck with the rest of your
interviews and everything that's going
on
and please stay safe in moscow and uh
hopefully i'll talk to you again in the
not so distant future
thank you very much it's been a pleasure
i hope some of my answers were
interesting enough exciting but uh i had
a great time and i
so i'm very happy you enjoyed the film
oh dude i i had a blast with it i
watched it again last night
you know to make sure i was ready that's
i think that is the biggest the biggest
compliment